[Music]
hello what's up how you guys doing I was
gonna say happy Monday but yesterday was
a holiday for us Martin Luther King J
today's Tuesday
we're gonna check out a cool game I put
in the thumbnail that it's kind of like
hotline Miami meets Max Payne because it
kind of has this like slow down mechanic
it's kind of like a top-down shooter
we're gonna go through the game I
haven't played it actually I've only
seen it enjoyed hotline Miami hopefully
there are some of those vibes here so I
might have to move my picture-in-picture
we'll see we'll take a look and let's
find out
that could be me if I had a lot of blood
on my face and no glasses all right four
days earlier 92 in Hong Kong the
bartender has been waiting for me mmm
old fashioned very good drink oh I'm
totally blocking the text huh
hold on one's like let's try this I'll
move myself like top right top writing
okay let me uh scroll through this as we
chat about it
I have this feeling that later I'm gonna
regret this top right location but
should be fine hurry why is it always
like that
so the time has finally come
all right I go back to the teahouse I'm
playing on PC right now it's also I
think gonna be on piece for I think if
you take a look at the wiki for it I
mean by risky assuming I said that right
ken Khan says game so I question where
hi what's up yeah what's up getting the
one how you doing thanks for the kind
words I coulda sworn it was coming out
for ps4 too but maybe it's not out yet
for ps4 so you just have to say I think
$17.99 right now I'm PC PC as only has a
braid now okay that makes sense
various like the first one maybe it's
like they want to see how they do and
then like you know obviously that'll be
a little bit telling for you know trying
to make it a console we can upgrade
weapons oh okay a pistol all right let's
here's the Dodge I can't dodge it Oh
right-click is like dive with God with
my cool slide switch gun get more
bullets hold they call me the Asian
truck ah dang it
I'll just say they call me the Asian
John wick and then I died John wick
would never die like that
all right I didn't see that new guy this
looks pretty good though it feels pretty
good so far
I'm not sure how I'd feel like on a
controller but obviously there's a slide
right there there's a little cartwheel
okay so I don't have this load I might
not have the slow slow down get him
what's the got it right it's also
interesting that they they can like
sense you like to shoot you through a
wall I guess
oh man bad bad aim bad aim can i buy
this yes it's out on Steam I think
there's like a deal for like 17 like
that so it'll be out first out if you
want to buy alright so there's
challenges with level and time limit no
slow motion perfect game definitely not
gonna get perfect game right now oh we
have 2 stars we can unlock the shotgun
or the SMG or the rifle let's let's go
SMG
all right how much is an upgrade oh look
at all those upgrades oh duels all right
we got that we gotta get that well
there's my SMG my crazy physics arm
didn't hear that right Oh perfect game
perfect game right all right wait we
shot twice oh maybe not perfect game
i right-click dodge to put maybe I
didn't like this is going well this is
going very well
wonder if you can't like upgrade the
Dodge
the spray and pray with the boys II got
a pistol taking shotgun yep I just gotta
get good I just gotta get good right
that's right and prayed
didn't work okay we just gotta get good
dude
okay I just gotta like push my mouth up
farther up
oh that guy's got goggles too well that
was pretty cool though did you see the
leap all right that one guy did a barrel
roll though he did a barrel roll on me
feels cheap stop rushing the third guy
yeah try not to but I'm not count like
taking into account his like bullet
spread yeah see I'm so fixated on
looking forward that I'm not like
dodging his cheerio and fat would be so
so upset with me yeah so Hong Kong
massacre huh
give me that shotgun four more shots
with the pump-action okay that didn't
hit can I not shoot and dodge at the
same time
you're bad at video games yeah sometimes
I admit that level to Hardee's level
today
oh here's dual pistols
the guy's got a rifle or an SMB who
seems legit hard I think I'm just
sucking a little bit too but it isn't
easy
that's for sure
[Music]
[Music]
leave the guy in the way back bullet
time is weird you have to hold it for
two okay
yeah I haven't bullet time dead either
but I was trying to do the challenge
which is no bullet time Wow don't know
how that guy that guy like you straight
Merc
looks like hotline Miami a little bit
slightly different but yeah has
definitely had the vibes
I like the music quite a bit the
spray-and-pray
that's a window ding it does the last
guy I was trying to go so slow
I got do more cartwheels
I mean this is one of those games were
like yeah once you get good and you like
perfect the runs and like what you need
to do
oh there was more dude don't know the
Tori post I think it's about the same I
think it's just me and I've been that
great right now slide is really slow not
gonna lie I think I should slide through
that door it's PC only right now and
then hopefully get bored at some point
let's see what it looks like to slide
through door OH
[Music]
now we're cooking with gas I just got to
be super hyper aggressive
dance and just like lunge at them
instead ford cartwheels all day no
defensive cartwheels
channel my inner John wick
why didn't that work
come on
I'm tried if you actually just used Walt
I'm sick needy you slow motion yeah all
right
got him got him in slow motion I wanted
the challenge ah we just didn't get
perfect game but hey it's okay
considering how many times I struggled
there we'll take it thank you for your
tips and thank you for your patience
guys I know that was a little bit tough
to watch
all right first interrogation police
officer Suwon Lowe
they'll get nothing from me you
inspiring me well thanks considering how
much I struggled there who like what's
the challenges on this one
under no slow mo and perfect game why
are they always the same that's fine the
dual pistols are pretty sick we can
upgrade upgrade so more bullets fire
rate you can get unlimited ammo that's
pretty good just go all-in on the SMG I
guess
which you can like snow pouch to like oh
we've got like an A
let's go
like a music I was a big bad guys down
this way I guess got it first try
definitely probably took too long
that was not fifty seconds we probably
got the second challenge though yeah the
no slow-mo we were five seconds short is
just cuz I didn't know where that guy
was that's alright jeez
two-headed dragons heroin lab Wow 30
seconds all right we'll try to do it 30
seconds can't afford anything right now
I can't see all the chat so there's
stuff bad stuff going on you should tell
me and then I can kick them or time them
out but definitely don't want any
toxicity
don't know how I survived real talk
oh go back fight
God um we're evolving we're evolving
chat alright who's who's mean who's
being not not so nice let's see I yeah
I'm pretty much like a Chinese cop
taking it on out all the bad guys maybe
it's like the corruptor maybe I'm kind
of bad I'm kind of good you know uh uh
where is the slurring that you're
speaking of Adrienne ei stop that John
Woo vibes yep definitely trying to
unlock my energy on fat
oh wow a minute 43 why that's such a
okay
vengeance is my oldest friend warehouse
of the Dragon I wonder there's got to be
boss fights right that's right be tough
let us channel the power positivity
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
you're doing so well
skyy go hyper sweetie
[Music]
once
oh I got the guy through the window I
did not
oh I'm out of bullets how come you get
to reload it's alright I'm a ninja
that's late
this crazy
really good
like slide over this going too slow
all right
by NASA
oh thanks you know I wish I could throw
throw the gun that'd be sick we're just
like maybe have like the ability to use
my fists or something maybe there was
something I missed they're not sure if
there is melee I didn't even try snick
but maybe I should've tried maybe I
should just like through it just just to
see I like an old-fashioned yeah what's
the secret in a little fashion it's the
brown sugar which strength and courage
if you drink old fashions
don't forget to upgrade my weapons you
got it all right start the level six
stars here we go
little spray and pray
that guy had to dance to
all right just so you know I cannot
throw the weapon I tried there through
the door
so good then so bad all at the same time
I thought he's still alive he's rag
dolling
I got a I got a initiate that dodge
slide soon I think like that
ok this is pretty this gets pretty crazy
when they start doing the dodge too
thanks Haley almost feels like sometimes
a pre-fire on you but they're probably
not it's just like their reaction that's
not what John wick would not just walk
through the door right
they both had this all right
whoa don't know high lips and all
honesty I did not deserve to live there
[Music]
oh that's tough that's tough I had to
dodge an assault rifle and a and a woman
call just now
all right
I tried to try the Dodge right in there
and shoot him Oh
Thanks
Wow comes out popping popping off there
fool of the purloined
oh you can walk through that
I think - again baby though I just
bought on seeing sick yeah it's out
today guys if you like guys and gals if
you guys want to check it out
this is I'm totally digging it loving
the music just gotta get better that's a
good percent gotta get better need those
fast twitch like reflex
oh I would through him this one stop
got spray-and-pray I guess
so it's gonna have a story kind of yeah
basically I think I'm trying to like
yeah it's like a it's a revenge story of
some sort
yeah well the shoppings good for cheaper
ones I guess
look Ben's also playing now Hong Kong
master
now's the last guy last guy he's just a
single pistol guy - alright the
struggles are real again
the guy behind them
seeking which is anyone gonna buy RT to
definitely a bunch of folks in the
office looking forward to it and our
review is actually up
GameSpy review you want to check that
out
I should actually try using the slow-mo
I'll play are the controls there's
really I don't really feel the input lag
I feel like dang I feel like a lot of it
is me like missing but there's
definitely like you kind of have to get
a little bit used to it and definitely
don't spray and pray like I am right now
like it's pretty like on point in terms
of like aiming properly and the Dodge is
pretty good I would say sometimes like I
can't initiate like a Dodge I'm shooting
say like kind of one I like Dodge and
then
anyway like
I wish there was like like a little bit
like a like a run or like a like walk
faster mechanic is
Oh finally sorry that took so long y'all
whoo boss why you're not feeling the
music I like the music it's pretty good
one of the previous levels I definitely
liked a little bit more who the rat this
is a boss boys ciao all right and I
start this level hello game
that's weird
there you go I don't know why I didn't
do that just now oh man we always have
enough to upgrade the SMG oh here we'll
go extra clip and see what that does
oh we got a boss fight
oh that's the box can I not meet a movie
yeah okay okay
with the extra clip
interesting back hoes it reminds me of
like you know when John was fighting
common in the and they're like shooting
each other like with the silencer is
like
[Applause]
oh ok ok so I guess I have to use the
area just to like hide from him because
he seems just like you can take some one
more shot
all right Nicki's Rochon Travolta to
face off one of my favorite movies
we used right back into it trying to see
how much damage
I cut on back
Oh Oh this guy's got the map hacks
ike cartwheeled too soon you shining
over six times yeah this guy's on uh
this is like Scarface the guys on a like
cocaine you can just take you just take
a bunch of shot oh you know I think
comes out this Friday that imagine you
want dance up here
oh wow he's gonna catch
oh you're sneaky Punk like you can
pre-fire on who
boys this guy made a concrete made of a
lot of girls and now he's gotta live
drugs and it was not easy as stop kony
Montaigne
what kill him like this Brenner I think
that's possible
oh my god he's like one shot hey I don't
know I don't I don't know why we didn't
just do that sooner I don't know why I
just didn't bob and weave on him that
seems like that shouldn't be the case I
feel like what should happen there as he
gets to threshold and like you have to
fight him at the end part because it was
way harder at the end where we were like
kind of circling the rooms against each
other call him a tactical nuna wish I
didn't think that would work I honestly
didn't think we could just kind of like
semi cheese them at the at the front but
whatever it's not boxing
crime or interrogation I guess this is
like us like recounting the whole thing
maybe
thought I was dead now I'm here for a
sweet revenge I'm gonna fight a gang
another gang now you know we haven't
used though as a slow motion
oh I heard the yeah
oh we doing oh alright alright we doing
we're doing crazy stuff off the off the
roofs no I'm so fixated by trying to see
how the hell on cartwheeling from one
roof to the other but we're making it
like it doesn't make sense I can make it
that far but alright
and I slide through this 100 we ABAB ah
dang it
that was sick oh man I cart wheeled into
the bathroom kill two dudes Laval you'll
kill some more dudes
I don't know the shotguns the best tool
for the job here but
[Music]
there's this llama
you want to see what it looked like I'm
sure he's cool too
oh oh I thought I I thought I like
killed myself jumped off the ledge you'd
like a flip off the ledge
don't know how to I didn't kill me
oh boy empty your mind there is no spoon
hello got him
you didn't see him but I got him this
game is pretty like I think if you could
just like master the movement the
slow-mo like I don't I don't know if you
saw it but he's even like waving the SMG
pretty sick looks like all of them are
always the same dough perfect game no
slow-mo and time we're almost to do a
wheeled SMG but not yet
oh you shot me from down there
I
[Music]
oh but it feels really good though once
you like and I like get everything going
[Music]
he's beginning to believe nevermind dude
that was a does a nice little run right
there though
not enough moving cars gotta use that
movement
[Music]
feels really good on your like on a roll
and then like just like really botched
[Music]
I'm not seeing enough moving I agree we
need more movement we need to believe
slow just like read that one bullet too
slow didn't even have the cursor on that
guy
[Music]
like me I cleared that rebounder why
[Music]
[Music]
why do you not see that guy in the
yellow I'm so stupid
that was good advice I was gonna look
back to see the name David - you're
right take 15 seconds to breathe refocus
that wasn't it
or not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
not enough movement yes what would be
good for this
I know what it is in the game
surprising anti sooner
[Music]
whoa
screw the challenge no man that's is I
feel like if I'm getting better with
just not using the slow-mo I'll be even
better whistling oh but I mean
considering I'm not even finishing
really the other challenges it's kind of
like this music is fired I agree Sikkim
load or mel bomba
we're almost there for Dooley's so
actually you know it it's just unlock
our SMG
I need that gun
got him damn we we went through that one
like no problem I just need to pick up
that gun I couldn't like like dodge and
pick up the gun at the same time whoo we
did in the time limit though that was
pretty good I don't feel like I slow
mode by musta hit space just like on
accident a slo-mo obviously is for the
Hong Kong style action people hell yeah
I'm talking about oh he's had like a
slot machines
we're like pachinko machines
Oh such a good run
we got around the machine there
oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
ah I got used to the other guns could
you say SMG now and how fast it fired
compared to like a assault rifle that I
haven't upgraded yet so assault rifles
like pretty slow
I'm not sure if I'm allowed to say when
we're gonna change it'll be
rolled into the other guy and until
these shocking
[Music]
but later this week for sure I'll have
some good stuff this week this looks
like how a 3d hotline Miami may look
like yeah shotguns get Rex
straight right back into the bullets
and I don't want to see someone like you
like the perfect it's gotta be nasty
we're de-evolving right now well game is
this this is Hong Kong massacre
[Music]
[Music]
houses
protip don't slide into gunfire slide
away from it I thought I could do a
forward flip and kill that one
oh that was close
I remember we got the automatic
whoo sorry headphone users alright
uh yeah Craig says bummed that it's not
out on ps4 today yeah I don't know when
I look it up the wiki was like it's out
well I'm playing on PC so it's not in PS
water sorry when we will try to circle
back and see what's up with that what's
up Emerson how are you doing
is there story yeah there's kind of like
a story that we've been going in between
like you know certain levels and
chapters you're kind of getting
interrogated and kind of like having
like recollections of like what's going
on can you run on the walls matrix tiles
like sort of Oh
[Music]
whoo-hoo I can't breathe I live that
long
[Music]
[Music]
oh come on he's ready so slow
rip
the movement I have to believe I'm neo
name is dope thanks Katie how much was
it I think on Steam it's like eighteen
dollars right now there's a sale till I
think 20 a Thursday
what happens when you use a not upgraded
weapon compared to your bio their
upgraded weapons
I see if we can maybe be s slow-mo Hey
we just need your eyes can be back
shots
oh did not see those guys oh I got I got
I got got there saw me spring praying
his dog
there is also slow flow time in this
[Music]
Oh a little two-for-one there at the end
oh that was tough
I was trying I've been trying to do it
cause of the challenges really Jason but
I really should be using the slow-mo
more I do find it interesting they have
to hold space to get the slow-mo but
yeah are we gonna see a chef now looks
like we're after the syndicate the
two-headed dragon snake soup you guys
ever have snake I've never had snake for
don't know if I want to either
oh you get movement speech we need that
I just got caught not that hard
too slow on the second Dodge
well that level is easy the ragdoll made
animations are F an amazing says JT
gammas games yes pretty good feels
pretty good
I just perfect games gonna be tough I
don't think I'll ever get perfect game
down nice I dine on Oh another boss that
tiger let's go oh we can upgrade to
tools let's do it all right we got them
dual smg's boys and girls oh this is the
same huh the boss is the same can we
just cheese them again
okay I think we can cheese them though
you can see way farther than I can name
sham Wang by the way
Oh
still got stuck in the door
the person
oh you see how I was still in a rolling
animation
cat chased cheese I really shouldn't be
choosing the boss is we should get up to
the end and show you guys the whole like
actual like boss mechanic we're like you
kind of like circle each other
who all right we finished like I don't
know two acts or something now we rated
the drug lab we're gonna shut this
syndicate down do we have some dirty
cops take your game better at this
yeah a little bit a little bit thanks
great Fox appreciate
you want smoke first and then talk all
right so we kill Changlong
that was us and it continues not really
sure why is recapping we go it's
interesting though I haven't really seen
too many new enemies or whatever yet so
oh there's three that's tough I like
this though I want I want more enemies I
definitely want more animals
whoa I'm digging this tractor
yeah the fully upgraded weapon seems
pretty opu though the my SMG is fully
upgrade now with God Dooley's got like
60 bullets got extra clips
what's up Zed sled nice shirt thank you
so it's pretty old one now I've been a
while since I've opted roping to your
shirt we should try some other weapons
huh let's try upgrading the rifle oh we
can't though it'd be nice to get the
movement speed here we'll start using a
different gun just because it does feel
a little dirty to be using these all the
time
really like in do you like going from
there you go hold on one second
Cody it is made by Moreschi it's also
published by for us
[Music]
feels bad
not sure how I looking back up deserved
[Music]
I wanted to want to go across the street
you shotgun all right let me grab one or
not
all right here's a shotgun
I ran out of bullets
don't want to spoil too much of the game
good luck have fun thank you
I think luckily this game doesn't have
too much to spoil
unless you're concerned about the story
but this isn't why I always play
oh I guess because of the spread
trucking that's I bet you can create the
shotgun biggest like nose you have
[Music]
Mack yeah the massacre
baby dodged to the right
[Music]
[Music]
goodnight yep
pre-fire you know music has changed from
level to level three boxes
we definitely move slower with the rifle
so that bonuses
if and when we can eventually get it
I could walk in there and go
see Tom Lupo professional killers wasn't
that that was it done
my life
the rifle I'm not good with the rifle
yet
you got pretty crispy would be with SMG
but the rifle has so far been a real
life struggle here
all right we need to take a second take
a second
yeah a lot of people not digging the
music I think it freezes
I'm
[Music]
and unless you're talking about like
bearings
I didn't eat it yet oh I got shotgun
well of are you on I'm not sure feel
like I'm on like the third act
like is this the beginning though I'm
like to access pass right now missing
like crazy
say my store would be awesome yeah
everything Mele there's no Mele though
and there's no like Miami but I do like
like all the dodging I just wish that I
need the movement speed things I could
see what the AR is like at faster
walking because
Hadj
[Music]
I really should be using slum all right
guys
this is that on Steam
I thought code that guy - yeah I don't
think I signed up the I don't feel spore
yet I thought it was gonna be
it's still my PE down the road but as of
right now a lot of people were telling
these guys they don't see it on the PSN
store so yeah only seems like maybe just
Steam right now where you can get it
okay for the sake of the stream I'm just
gonna go back to our tried and true
[Music]
as I say that we are struggling still
yeah
sweet hey run it back I want to see the
same replay over
whoo all right
come on
I'm not ragequitting I'm gonna at least
finish this level or just die
I seen it
for the sake of the screen
[Music]
doesn't feel those ones feel real bad
when even look like
[Music]
[Music]
man
tell him fat simulator that's correct
breaking like
I have played hotline Miami but it feels
different than hotline Miami
Sebastian
yeah I see like there's not much I can
do there as I'm crossing he's like
please flying across today so either I
have to just kill him before we cross
or
[Music]
we have your name please my name is a
I'm gonna get my life
[ __ ] slow-mo today is this Mac to pull D
I don't know I just played whatever is
right off the bat so it might be
since that one spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I just press the wrong boy
difficult really is far just normal
the only thing I'm not doing I haven't
really slow mode Sam I'm just walking
this spread this is not the beginning
we're about I don't know how many levels
but we're like on the third aqui
so stupid I don't think it's unfair fist
now none of this is unfair this is all
my life
coming didn't dodge you can do
everything in this like like you just
got to be good
all right we got him finally geez we did
it
no access to bullet time I do have it I
just haven't been using it for part of
it because of the challenge but I don't
know I should here I'll try to use it
this next level this next level is gonna
be a last one though so I'll try to use
both time more this time I'll try to use
it a little bit more
that's why right there alright there's
gonna be a fun level hopefully we can
get through this one without it we can
see the crazy on
I don't maybe that's not the right way
to go
bad way
that was a death trap
two guys with SMG
it's so hard to control that's full-on
slow-mo right there it's really hard to
control that though a guy II don't even
know if I could dodge again once I
initiated a dog I dodged into slow oh
yeah so you have to hold slow-mo you
have to hold slow for it to keep going
I would say
we can fight it let's do it
[Music]
so we got
this is that's I don't know maybe it's
just weird because I haven't easy
[Music]
shotgun dude hello do more try it again
I will try it again
I can't like rotate it fast death does
not become I've got achievement
so that was me like using it a little
bit as I dodged and letting go
try not to die
slid right into his boots
oh the moment I let go it's very cool
though
oh there was you guys
trying to I'm trying to do the
I'm dead I'm dead right I was like why
did I roll there all right
China trying to do the like slo-moes
then trigger the slow-mo fast enough
their speedruns are gonna be crazy all
right we're just gonna try to beat the
level
yeah we're just gonna be loud
well this level is interesting after
you're not using it that long is really
actually kind of weird to use it but I
guess it's it's totally fun mechanic and
I think if you're gonna like play it the
first time through you probably want to
use some slow mode just get those really
cool cinematic moments that was Hong
Kong Massacre that's about an hour and a
half where I don't know how far along in
the story we are but we kind of like
finished like two chapters or so and
we're starting the third chapter there I
think if assume you want column chapters
check that out if you want to you on
Steam I believe its 1799 right now it's
10% off yeah 1799 unfortunately I guess
it's not on ps4 yeah I know there's a
bunch of people asking for ps4 but let's
see we are releasing the Hong Kong
Massacre a bit early on Steam and it's
available now and it looks like ps4
version Oh supposed to be the 22nd but
maybe he's a little later we'll have to
see maybe it's gonna come with an update
later check the store maybe later for
that but that was from Moreschi games
themselves or tweet about 18 hours ago
that it was supposed to come out for ps4
today 22nd we'll be back tomorrow 11:00
a.m. I'm not sure what game yet because
I thought I was gonna have something for
tomorrow but it's been pushed back from
embargo so come back Thursday we're
gonna have two streams might be starting
a little earlier that day maybe a 9 a.m.
and then 11 ly 11 a.m. if I can talk
Friday there's the anthem demo so
hopefully we'll be getting into that as
well and stay tuned against off for more
coverage this week of all games and all
that fun stuff thank you guys for tuning
in I'm Eric thank you guys for stopping
by hanging out I appreciate it until
next time go out there play Hong Kong
massacre shout outs to John Woo gosh I'm
fat